what's up I'm Deidre Behar here with the
gorgeous Sierra Ramirez and we're gonna
play a little game of what's on your
phone most used emoji most definitely
the monkey that doesn't why are you
saying naughty things no I got the
cutest line it doesn't matter what I'm
saying I just like always just love
adding it oh he's cute yeah you're right
most used app probably snapchat yeah
you're a big snapchat girl I love
snapchat if I don't snap I'm just
constantly washing other people's it's
pretty addicting especially with all
those there's an app that you're
embarrassed to admit you have oh you can
do the Domino's have don't be afraid to
tell us you like wearing de lon what is
that it's this game I've played ever
since high school basically like you mow
the lawn wait do you actually do this
Evon pretty I get intense like yes it's
it's a very addicting last thing you
googled I was looking up an edit James
concert poster I want to hang it on my
wall do you want to buy it as art yes oh
I love that you love at a James I do
love Etta James album or a song people
would be surprised to know is on your
phone my all-time faves butterfly by
crazy town you're my butterfly sugar
baby oh my lady come come on Lady
Oh such a good one I love it back it's
so good karaoke song - oh my gosh I feel
like it people have set it out right now
we would just murder it we would kill he
would kill and they're not really song
that is most played on your iTunes
something you just never get sick of I
think I have to say it is all of
lemonade I already know the answer you
drink the lemonade and I didn't hit you
hard all would hit me hard
he's nothing back for more person you
FaceTime with the most probably Jeff my
boyfriend's and what do you guys talk
about everything I mean honestly I don't
even think we talk on the phone it's
just always it's always FaceTime last
person you texted oh it was actually
Jeff can we ask what you've chatted
about I said did I leave my straightener
on oh he said I'll check when I get home
if my house is silver huh